well this took me 16 months to figure
out my Darwin outfit a pure adaptability
how many times I go to the pool and come
out and go to a restaurant after going
to the gym and presenting all in the
same shorts I'm like everyone else's
shorts are inferior one like you're just
not adaptable darwinian I would win
people were like oh I want to go to the
pool and I'm like I'm ready I want to go
to the gym like I'm ready look I gotta
go change I'm like it sucks dude this is
a Darwin outfit I'm adaptable I
can do whatever I want I think that's
angle I'm gonna explain the sentence
like I'm Darwin as right now like
you're cute we get wet you're you
go to a nice restaurant you're fine I go
to the gym